good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight it used to be before
liberals embraced authoritarianism that
they would talk a lot about rights
you're right why right everything was a
right a right to Health Care Miranda
Rights you can debate whether those are
rights or not
but if you're talking about rights you
at some point want to identify the most
basic human right of all what is that
well of course it's the right of
self-defense that's the essential right
upon which all other rights depend if
you can't defend yourself you can't
defend your family and your property you
don't have any rights at all you're a
slave by definition
so you may be wondering in this moment
of creeping authoritarianism how is the
right to self-defense doing in our
country
we could give some kind of long lecture
but instead how about some examples
consider two shootings that took place
at gas stations in the past year in the
United States the first shooting
occurred around 2PM on October 6 in the
state of Missouri a 23 year old felon
called Jayvon Taylor who had a long
criminal record convictions for armed
robbery for example began threatening a
female clerk apparently because the gas
station didn't carry the kind of cigars
that he wanted
that's what an off-duty fireman called
Anthony Santi who was inside
decided to step in he told Jayvon Taylor
to leave the store
well in response to that Taylor began
threatening him and then ran toward his
SUV outside Santi followed him outside
because he suspected that Jayvon Taylor
would retrieve a gun from the car and
that's exactly what he did Javon Taylor
pulled an illegal handgun with an
extended magazine from his SUV
Santi not wanting to get shot put Taylor
in a headlock
and that's one Javon Taylor handed the
gun to his girlfriend and his girlfriend
shot the unarmed fireman in the back
killing him
it was an execution it's not a close
call if footage is online we're not
going to show it to you because it's
awful
but if you have any doubt you can watch
it so there's no debate about what
happened here and yet the local social
justice D.A Gene Peters Baker refused to
press charges against the person who
killed the fight the firefighter
now why well there may have been a
political component and we know that
because online BLM activists immediately
celebrated The Killing
on racial grounds Jayvon Taylor is black
Anthony Santi was white that was enough
for them they're glad he's dead
now consider the second gas station
shooting this one happened just before
midnight less than a month ago in Austin
Texas an armed man with a long criminal
record called Marquis Demps walked into
a Shell station and became violent
here's a report from the local Fox
station describing what happened next
customers who frequent the family-owned
Shell gas station on East MLK in
Springdale can't say enough good things
about 25 year old employee yaseen Naz
they're stunned to hear Nas is charged
with first-degree murder after police
say he shot and killed 42 year old
Marquis Demps outside the store late
Saturday night according to court
documents Demps came into the store and
caused a verbal disturbance that turned
physical that there was some type of
altercation happening inside the store
and that's what started everything Demps
waving a knife at the workers so Naz
grabbed a gun telling him to leave
instead Demps began trashing the store
NASA's father showing us the damaged
merchandise and display cases the credit
card machine ripped out of the counter
as Demps left Naz followed him into the
parking lot and shot it multiple times
through his car window
so a guy with a criminal record and a
knife in his hand starts trashing your
store and then runs outside to his car
you see Naz told police later that he
shot Marquee Demps because he feared for
his life he thought the guy was going to
get a gun and come back and kill him and
that's a reasonable fear of course the
Anthony santi's murder demonstrates that
it is but in this case the D.A of
Sorrows funded anti-police political
activist called Jose Garza is pressing
charges against the clerk he wants he's
seen naz a man who's widely respected in
his community man who actually
contributes to our society as you just
heard
he's trying to send that man to prison
for the rest of his life
so but these two cases together consider
them in tandem what's the message well
the message is if a violent felon starts
terrorizing people and you're still
ripping your store apart on which you
rely for your livelihood
you can't do anything
if he goes back to his car to get a gun
you have to let it happen
so get shot or go to jail for the rest
of your life those are your choices
which of course are not really choices
at all
and these are not isolated cases that we
cherry pick to make some political point
it's happening everywhere we saw it
happen to Jose Alba last summer in New
York he's the bodega clerk the
prosecutor is sent to Rikers Island on a
murder charge because he fought back
when a thug another convicted felon
attacked him with his girlfriend in the
store
now that charge was ultimately dropped
after the public flipped out because it
was so unfair but Alba left this country
for the Dominican Republic because he
saw where things are going
self-defense the Cornerstone of all
freedoms without which you cannot be
free you are owned
self-defense is becoming illegal in
effect in a lot of places
and not just in very liberal places
like New York City even in states with
some of the strongest self-defense laws
on the books Arizona for example allows
residents to shoot trespassers on their
property
so 73 year old George Allen Kelly lived
right on the border now you may have
heard that Joe Biden opened the border
to millions and millions of people
from other countries whose identities we
don't know to just walk in so if you
live on the border this has changed your
life completely and it scared you
so George Allen Kelly was one of those
people lives on the border he's seeing
this firsthand now he is in jail tonight
charged with first degree murder because
he's shot an illegal alien who
trespassed onto his Ranch in Kino
Springs let's listen two miles from the
border this happened January 30th just
the other day
now we don't know the details of the
altercation between the man in prison
and the man he killed
but the man in prison has no record of
killing anyone else he's not a convicted
felon he does not have a violent history
the man he killed was an illegal migrant
called Gabriel Quinn butima and he was
deported several times from the United
States but let back in we're not
attacking him just noting him that's
true
so George Allen Kelly apparently felt
threatened and shot that illegal migrant
but prosecutors did not give him the
benefit of that they instantly charged
him with first degree murder
so here he is George Allen Kelly this is
the guy who according to Arizona
authorities is a dangerous risk to
Public Safety who must spend the rest of
his life in prison assessed does he seem
dangerous to you
I noticed coming in your honor my wife
is in present in the court
may I ask her to make an appointment for
a audio visual conference you're not not
been able to talk to her or anyone
so that's something that has to be
discussed with the detention
um facility downstairs so that
conversation would have to be had with
them sir okay so if your wife wants to
have communication with you she can go
to the Sheriff's Office and they can go
ahead and make the proper accommodation
that they need to make I appreciate you
giving that instruction
is an elderly man who can barely walk
who's never been convicted of a violent
crime
and he's being treated like a child by
some disembodied voice from some fascist
that's that's what you just saw
now the judge in this case is called
Emilio Velazquez now who's a million
philosophers he's a judge he doesn't
have a law degree he's not a lawyer and
yet he's a judge he's an elected
politician and he is allowing the
prosecution of an American citizen who
exercised his rights under Arizona law
and his most basic human right which is
if someone comes on to your property and
you feel threatened by it you have a
right to defend yourself by force period
but Velazquez does not acknowledge that
right and so he set the bail for this
elderly man whose wife is living alone
in their home right near the border at a
million dollars
so news of this case obviously traveled
past Arizona and people were justly
outraged by what is being done to this
man so people tried to raise money to
pay that bail on GoFundMe
but GoFundMe wouldn't allow that this
elderly man rotting in jail while his
wife lives alone on a border that the
Democratic party has kept open
you can't raise money for his bail
they shut down GoFundMe shut down the
effort to raise bail for this guy now of
course you can raise money for BLM as
they burn our country down
to make sure Donald Trump is not
re-elected but you're not allowed to
raise money for people being held on a
million dollars bail on first-degree
murder charges for defending their own
property along an open border
true insanity and a danger to all of us
even in Texas which in some places still
a free state self-defense is slowly
becoming illegal a few weeks ago a thug
walked into a taco shop holding what
looked to be a gun scared the hell out
of everybody inside and stole their
money he pointed this gun turned out to
be fake at several customers
how would you feel if you were there in
the restaurant and some lunatic with a
gun starts shoving the Barrel in
people's faces and stealing their money
well one Brave man stood up and
eliminated the threat
here it is
a man wearing a mask and gloves inside
the Taqueria around 11 30 Thursday night
pointing what looks like a gun at
customers while demanding money as some
hide and throw cash this man takes
action just as the robber heads to the
door still with his gun drawn
picked up the money turned around and
left and that's when the customer got up
and shot him
[Music]
realizing that Robert's gun is plastic
returning the stolen money to customers
taking a sip of his drink and leaving
before police arrived
so it'd be interesting we should do this
Play that video for the entire country
and let's have a national referendum on
what ought to happen to the man who shot
the Armed robber you're eating with your
family in a restaurant some lunatic and
a mask comes in and shoves a gun in your
face which you think is a gun and steals
your money and somebody stands up and
shoots him back
what percentage of Americans think that
guy should go to jail right around zero
probably
but Houston Police along with the County
district attorney are putting that man
in front of a grand jury to send him to
prison
they're saying he shot the criminal one
too many times okay
it's not hard to see why people are
making sure they're putting down violent
thugs if they don't they'll get out of
jail and start terrorizing more people
that is happening everywhere just
happened in Tupelo Mississippi in
September Mississippi State controlled
by Republicans but politicians in
Mississippi start letting felons out on
parole and that would include a man
called Chris Copeland who's 26. he had
multiple convictions for burglary and
auto theft Copeland will out on
probation executed a clerk inside a
Chevron after robbing him
he made that clerk a man called parmir
Singh sit down and then shot him in the
back of the head this footage is awful
but it's real turn away if you don't
want to see it here it is
[Applause]
this
beautiful
[Music]
just executed them
so politicians can feel like good and
virtuous people by giving a second
chance to found him by the way felons do
deserve a second chance not everyone in
prison deserves to be there but when you
let people out wholesale
and they don't keep track of them just
expect the best you're going to let
Psychopaths like Chris Copeland into the
general population and they're going to
execute store clerks who are the last
people who deserve to be executed
they're working for like eight bucks an
hour to sell you lotto tickets
meanwhile people who defend themselves
against criminals get the maximum
possible sentence the government gets to
defend itself with bodyguards
politicians have tons of bodyguards you
pay for
Congress is so afraid of the people they
govern they built a wall around the
capitol this week
but you can't fight back and we began to
see this accelerate in 2020 during the
BLM riots so a BLM mob broke the gate
into Market Patricia McCloskey's
property in St Louis they were having
dinner all of a sudden the mob shows up
and so in response they did what you
would do if you were awake you grab your
Firearms you don't shoot anybody back
off those Firearms were lawfully owned
they were on their property as was the
mob
here's what it looked like
[Applause]
[Music]
remember that they were racist right a
group of Highly entitled children of
orthodontist showed up on their property
to threaten them and they said back off
so they're racist at the Washington Post
and then of course the Soros back
prosecutor called Kim Gardner
charged them charged the class the
mccloskeys with crime not the mod the
mccloskeys for daring to defend
themselves their guns were seized
now the point of this of course is not
to make anybody safer just the opposite
and St Louis has not become safer has
become much more dangerous under Kim
Gardner in the city has experienced its
highest murder rate in decades
so Public Safety is not the point the
point is disarming you so you can't
defend yourself against their plans for
you
now thankfully Mark McCloskey and his
wife were pardoned
these outrageous charges by the governor
of the state thank God subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight